لا تزال بعض أجزاء أتلانتا تقوم
بالتنظيف بعد عاصفة مطيرة مفاجئة وقوية للغاية
يوم الخميس، مما أدى إلى هطول
أمطار غزيرة غمرت المدينة في
فترة زمنية قصيرة، وقد حدث ذلك في
جيوب صغيرة هنا وهناك، وفي الواقع
قال مكتب العمدة حوالي ثلاث
ساعات  هطلت الأمطار في 15 دقيقة فقط
وحاصرت الكثير من سائقي السيارات في
الشوارع التي غمرتها المياه بما في ذلك رجل نبيل
كان لا بد من إنقاذه بطريقة دراماتيكية للغاية وتم
التقاط كل ذلك
بفيديو كاميرا الجسم، ألقِ نظرة على
نوع
المشكلة الكلاسيكية الجاهزة هيا  فقط هيا انتبه وراقب
نفسك وأنت تحاول
إيقاظ هذا الرجل
[تصفيق]
لقد
فهمت، في أي نقطة أدركت أنهم
هنا وأن الشارع الموجود خارج
مقرك مباشرة كان مغمورًا بالمياه
لدرجة أنه سيكون هناك سائق هناك
في سيارته عالقة لذلك كنت في الواقع
مسافرًا في شارع P متجهًا إلى
مكالمة أخرى عندما لاحظت السيارة المتوقفة
في تلك المرحلة لم أكن أعلم بوجود
أحد في السيارة في ذلك الوقت أه
الماء نعم كنا واقفة
السيارة هناك للتأكد من عدم وجود أي
مركبة أخرى عالقة في تلك المنطقة
أه فقط بضع ثواني في الثانية من
الثواني لقد بدأت للتو في رؤية السيارات
بدأت تنجرف وبعد ذلك
بدأت أسمع الصراخ وذلك عندما
أعتقد أن الكابتن كان هناك  وبعد ذلك
أعلم أنه كان هناك راكب فعلي
في السيارة وبعد ذلك أيها الكابتن، كيف حدث أن
كنت هناك أو رأيت ما كان
يحدث، قصتي
مختلفة قليلاً حسنًا،
لدي زميل في العمل توري  هنري
هي المساعدة التنفيذية لشعرنا
الحالي رودريك سميث وقد
أبلغتني أن شخصًا ما اصطدم بشجرة
ولذلك خرجت للتو للتحقق من الأمر
ولاحظت أن هذا الرجل كان
يغرق في سيارته أو بدا وكأنه
يغرق في سيارته.  لقد بدأت للتو
العمل وأود أن أعزو ذلك إلى
تدريبي